hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
today stanford ranks as one of the top
universities in the world
in this video let's take a trip back in
time
can you solve the stanford entrance exam
questions from 1892
here's a trigonometry question
express tangent squared of theta plus
cotangent squared of theta in terms of
cosine theta
here's an advanced algebra question
if a b and c are in harmonical
progression
prove b plus a all over b minus a plus b
plus c all over b minus c is equal to 2.
can you figure it out
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution
so the trigonometry question is pretty
straightforward
tangent of theta is equal to sine of
theta over cosine of theta and the
cotangent of theta is the reciprocal of
that
we substitute these in to tangent
squared of theta plus cotangent squared
of theta
and now all we need to do is simplify
sine squared of theta in terms of cosine
of theta
we can do this with the identity sine
squared of theta is equal to one minus
cosine squared of theta
and when we substitute that in that's
about as simplified as we can get
we have one minus cosine squared of
theta all over cosine squared of theta
plus cosine squared of theta all over
one minus cosine squared of theta
so now let's go to the algebra question
the key part of this question
is what is a harmonic progression
i personally did not know this and i'll
admit i had to look it up
in a harmonic progression the
denominators are in an arithmetic
progression so if the first term is one
over x
the next term is one over x plus d
then the next term is one over x plus
two d
then we have one over x plus three d and
so on each time we're adding this common
difference of d to the denominator
so we might as well say that a is equal
to one over x b is equal to one over x
plus d and c is equal to one over x plus
two d for some common difference d
so we'll take this and we'll substitute
it in and see if we can simplify our
expression
so we first do b plus a all over b minus
a
we get a kind of complicated fraction
but we can simplify it with a little
trick
we'll multiply the numerator and
denominator by the quantity x plus d
times x
this simplifies the numerator to be x
plus the quantity x plus d and the
denominator becomes x minus the quantity
x plus d
the numerator becomes 2x plus d and the
denominator becomes a negative d
so we have the opposite
of the fraction 2x plus d all over d
now let's simplify b plus c over b minus
c
we'll substitute in our terms of the
harmonic progression
and now we'll use the same trick to
simplify
we'll multiply the numerator and
denominator by the quantity x plus d
multiplied by the quantity x plus 2d
the numerator becomes x plus 2d plus the
quantity x plus d and the denominator
becomes x plus 2d minus the quantity x
plus d
this simplifies to be 2x plus 3d all
over d
so now we need to add these two terms
together
so when we do that we actually cancel
out these two x terms
and then we get 2d all over d
which simplifies to be 2.
so we've proven that this expression
simplifies to be two
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can map
the world a better place
please subscribe for free to the news
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle presh
mind yourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support